thank you very much for joining us
nearly all votes have been counted in
turkey and it seems certain voters will
be going back to the polls in two weeks
time with more than 99 of ballot boxes
opened no presidential candidate has yet
managed to pass 50 of the vote let's
take a closer look at the figures as
they stand president recep type erdogan
has
49.41 his main rival kamalesh Derulo has
nearly 45 percent that's according to
State media as results were coming in
president erdogan said he'd be ready if
the election went to a second round
[Music]
seemed that the margin with the closest
opponent is more than 2 million votes
and with the final result we will see a
wider margin we don't know if we will
have a runoff but if this is the result
of the first round the results of the
runoff will be the same if our nation
has decided to go to a second round we
will respect that decision
opposition presidential candidate rule
also said he'd be ready for a runoff
hasn't gotten the result he wanted we
have to wait for the final results if
the first round wasn't enough to receive
the Mandate we are going to get it in
the runoff election
a third presidential candidate sinan
owan has secured more than five percent
of the votes so far his endorsement
could be crucial in a runoff so far he's
refusing to back erdogan or kileshirolu
it seems elections will go the second
round and Turkish nationalists and
camalists will be the determinants of
the runoff dear friends there'll be
another difficult 15 days ahead of us
and during this time if the elections
are completed with the current results
and go to the second round we will do
our best to make this process a good one
for our nation and our country at this
time we are not saying that we will
support one party or the other
well we have two correspondents on this
story The Sarah will speak to Zenna and
gazian tape in just a moment but first
let's go to cinem go silgloo who's in
Istanbul Forest so a cinema with most of
the votes counted it looks like we're
headed to a runoff talk to us first
about what we can expect in the next few
hours
welcome we are expecting the Supreme
election board to announce the official
results so far the results that we have
been receiving since yesterday are
coming from the agencies and the
agencies are gathering this data from
the political parties and now it's time
for the blueprint documents to be
counted but it can take some time maybe
we are not gonna hear it today maybe
tomorrow maybe in a couple of hours it
depends but we are hearing that still
the schools that have been used as
polling stations yesterday some of them
are still full of ballot papers ballot
boxes so the logistics are also binding
here but as the Supreme election board
or higher election board announces the
official results results everything is
going to be official we are going to
know that the exact votes that each
candidate and each parliamentary member
can that received fully and so a runoff
in two weeks that's a long time what can
we expect from the candidates
in that time
well I can tell that I can tell that
many Turks are already tired because the
turkey has been in an election
atmosphere for the last nearly two years
and now there's a runoff and there are
two more weeks which means the
candidates the the two candidates
president rejected and the opposition
candidate cannot coach DeRulo will
continue campaigning depending on their
plans of course so during those two
weeks they will they will try to analyze
where they lost where the parties were
weak and they will try to invest in
those locations for instance I must
mention president registry paradon
situation we know that after the peace
process what the Kurds have collapsed
the Kurds were kind of offended with
President rejects especially the
government's more security oriented
policies following the failed coup
attempt distance the Kurds and the
ruling God parties and in the
Southeastern regions where Kurdish
dominated City these are the votes went
for a CHP the national the Republican
party took him and probably Ardon will
analyze because he needs those votes and
definitely who is the third candidate
who made a great jump during this
election no one was expecting such a
high turnout for him he will be
supporting either erdogan or cholesterol
but everything depends on negotiations
so until the second round it's all about
negotiations
thank you for that all about
in Istanbul let's go now to Zena Hotel
who's in gaziante foreign how are these
results being viewed Where You Are
well the press president has the lead
but it is a slight lead very different
than 2018 when he had an outright
victory of 53 percent and his main
content Contender had 33 so it is being
seen that the president did lose some
support whether it's because of the
economy whether the way the government
handled the earthquake the disaster in
southern provinces or whether he
Consolidated too much power and people
were against that but at the end of the
day he maintained his majority in
Parliament he and along with his allies
which gives him the advantage really
because even if the opposition wins in
the runoff vote if there is going to be
a runoff vote it will be very hard for
the opposition to push through its
promises to change the the system of
government back to a parliamentary
system from a presidential one and if
erdogan forms or new alliances in
Parliament he can call for a referendum
and and end the new election so a lot of
uncertainties and then those there are
those in the opposition and who are also
disappointed because they felt that the
opposition first of all the killer
darogle was the wrong candidate he
wasn't able to reach out and and Chip
Away the conservative votes uh from the
from the president's party and it's not
just that they're also questioning the
alliance with the pro-kurdish hdp which
the Turkish government considers a
political wing of the pkk so that also
hurt the opposition so both sides are
going to have to you know political
calculations in the next days and the
next few weeks if they're going to head
to a run-off battle and that third
candidate that synonym was talking about
he did say that he will not call on his
supporters to vote for the opposition if
the hdp the pro Kurdish party is still
part of that system so a lot of backdoor
dealings negotiations in the coming days
if that runoff vote is to take place
okay Xena thank you for that Zina holder
live there in gaziante